the serial killer known as Son of Sam is
speaking out in his first major
television interview in a decade David
Berkowitz terrorized New York City in
1976 and 1977 he used a 44 caliber
handgun to commit random shootings
across the city in all Berkowitz killed
six people and wounded seven others
police eventually arrested him exactly
40 years ago today he was convicted and
sentenced to more than 300 years in
prison
Maurice debois I spoke with Berkowitz
for a CBS News special here's a preview
of tomorrow night's broadcast people
will never understand where I came from
them and how much I I try to explain it
they wouldn't understand what what would
it it was to to walk in darkness in the
summer of 1977 New York it's mine we had
a blackout you know it was a very very
different time and people were afraid to
walk around the city is preoccupied with
the killer who and one note signed
himself the Son of Sam dark brown hair
who were gunned down as they set in
parked cars or walk the sidewalks of the
Bronx and queens by the time I got time
she was dead in the street my daughter
was 18 years old and that's what he took
out of my heart 18 years he struck again
over the weekend shooting a young couple
in a Brooklyn Lovers Lane and today the
girl died
The Killers sixth victim he's wounded
seven others oh my god oh my god we've
been shot we've been shot I should have
been dead what do you remember from the
shooting itself the bullet totally
destroyed the left eye and most of my
right eye where the bullet struck me
right in the head I never felt anything
it just hit me directly in the head and
it crew travelled right across to the
right side of my head the only
substantial Clues so far have been two
letters including one mail to the New
York Daily News I was writing about a
dog that talks to and gave them orders
to kill
serial killers about to walk in here on
top of us
that look like I'm right oh hey god
bless you
Maurice debois it's an honor to meet you
sir thank you thank you for talking with
us Sheriff okay it's a it's a big step
you know I still I miss ya miss
misgivings and nervousness the short
short things understood is this a
special place for you yeah it is yeah
it's a place of refuge I've been locked
up since the time of my arrest just
under 40 years you just turned 64 yeah
just turned 64 yeah what would you tell
23 year-old David Berkowitz today turn
around before it's too late because
destruction is coming you know as far as
I'm concerned that that was not me that
was not me there's this even the that
name I hate that name I despise that aim
that which name that moniker Son of Sam
that was a demon Maurice debois joins us
now what's been his life like in prison
and his genuine remorse you know I think
you all have done prison interviews
before it's at once disturbing unnerving
chilling to be in there what's most
striking to me about him is his
unremarkable miss if you will 64 year
old man soft around the middle he looks
like anybody else he tries to sort of go
under the radar and live that way and
stay that way and keep to himself and at
the same time be a minister to people in
prison he's a born-again Christian that
was the chapel we were in that's where
he finds the most comfort he was stabbed
years ago but that's a long time ago the
guys he lives with now barely know of
Son of Sam barely know who he is and he
likes it that way he's a little reticent
as you could see about doing this
interview but he did it he's always said
the devil made him do it
yeah that's right that's right he had
demons he struggled with them as a child
that's his explanation it's not
satisfactory to most of us to any of us
quite frankly it's it's really out there
but that's what he said he still
believes that now that's what he said he
refers to what is it dark time but he
wants to move on from him what was that
like for you walking in there and
sitting down
how did you prepare for that well you
try to stay focused right but as you
could see they're a little reticent
myself I've done many Prison interviews
before but this is different it's a
serial killer its Son of Sam you try to
stay focused and and and ignore all that
other stuff and stay with the material
but you power through it
Maurice debois very much yeah I can't
wait to sort or you can see the CBS News
special Son of Sam the killer speaks
tomorrow night at airs at 10:00 9:00
central right here on CBS